adrian thank you very much very much and
if you're just joining us we'll start
with that breaking news there's been a
breakthrough in a three-year dispute
between qatar
and three other arab nations saudi
arabia has agreed
to reopen its airspace and land and sea
border
to qatar from monday ending the blockade
on the state
kuwait which has been the main mediator
in the dispute made the announcement on
the eve
of a gulf cooperation council summit in
riyadh
saudi arabia the uae egypt and bahrain
imposed a blockade on qatar in 2017
accusing it of supporting terrorism
qatar has always
rejected the claim let's bring in
ramekuri who's the director of global
engagement and a senior
public policy fellow at the american
university of beirut he joins us
via skype from new york thanks very much
indeed for being with us so give us your
reaction to the
significance of this news well my
reaction is
good i'm very pleased this is good news
whenever any kind of tensions between
countries and the arab region
are resolved then one has to be happy
the significance is not clear yet
because this was a
fake conflict from the beginning the
charges against
cut out by the four arab countries were
really quite uh outrageous
and most of the world saw them that way
and therefore very few people if any
supported the boycott um this was this
is a political dispute there is a
political dispute between the uae
saudi arabia and qatar and other
countries about how to deal with
political trends
ramikori we seem to have lost our guests
there just uh
talking about also the the influence of
where this will take
the middle east and that whole region
let's bring in heidi jocastra who's
following developments from washington
d.c and hardy we've seen
recently the normalization of relations
between some gulf countries
and israel put us put this current
development in the context
for us
sure the guiding principle between this
in by this
foreign policy team led by jared kushner
the president's son-in-law
has been to unite the countries in this
region against
iran and that is what when the driving
factors was
in the push to normalize diplomatic
relations between israel
and several arab nations that we saw
occur
at the end of last year now he had also
been working until the wee hours over
the phones where
according to the reporting of the
reuters news agency citing
an unnamed u.s official that kushner was
on the phones himself trying to
negotiate this breakthrough
and that it finally has emerged i know a
big question remaining out
there is whether or not this
breakthrough is just between saudi
arabia
and qatar or whether it also involves uh
the other arab nations well according to
the reporting
uh by reuters and by the associated
press
this may be a deal that's emerging
between all of the parties and that in
fact tomorrow's
signing ceremony which we're still
trying to learn more about
in saudi arabia we'll have a kushner in
attendance he'll be
joined by brian hook a u.s state
department representative
another u.s official as well and that
this signing agreement
it appears may be more than just saudi
arabian qatar it may involve
the other gcc nations as well again this
is uh still breaking we're trying to get
this confirmed
but what we know from the reuters news
agency is that jared kushner
had had a large part driving this effort
it is something
that he was trying to race against the
clock in finding
some sort of resolution given that
president trump will be out of office
within 16 days
and to add this emerging emerging deal
if it sticks
as one more victory diplomatically
between the trump administration
negotiated in the gulf region would
certainly be something that the
president
can celebrate in his waning days in
office
i suppose looking back on it though
there was a truck a part that
uh president trump played at the start
of all this that perhaps
uh some people might have said was was
unhelpful and and
encouraged the the other countries to to
blockade
that's right and certainly that brings
up the images of president trump's first
uh first trip out of the u.s as
president of course he chose
saudi arabia as the destination
really cozying up to saudi arabia from
the very first
beginning days of his administration
then of course
uh there was the assassination of jamal
khashoggi and president trump's
unwillingness to condemn saudi arabia
condemn the role of the crown prince
despite the u.s intelligence conclusions
that it was likely a directed operation
coming from the crown prince himself so
certainly the president had
faced much criticism over his response
to saudi arabia coming
even from members of his own party the
republicans and we saw
congress throughout the years of the
trump administration
in their rare departures from president
trump members of his party again the
republicans voting
uh in measures that were very critical
of saudi arabia its role
in uh the war in yemen so to go from
that point to the to the last
two weeks of president trump's
administration where he can
call this a win again if the deal sticks
that was negotiated by his own
son-in-law jared kushner who
long called peace in the middle east his
his predominant goal in his role in the
white house as a senior advisor
this is certainly something that the
trump administration will likely
celebrate we'll talk a lot about in the
coming days hi deejay castro thank you
very much indeed for the time being and
i'm sure we'll talk to you again soon in
the meantime al jazeera's jamal shayal
is live for us
from doha so jamal for people who are
just tuning in give us a quick sense of
what this deal
involves and and who has to give what
well um what it involves in terms of the
commitments that will be taken by
all sides uh is yet to be clear and
most likely we will not hear about it
until uh the summit take place takes
place itself however
what we know it we know what it won't
involve it won't involve the 13 demands
that the blockading countries
uh said must be met by qatar in order
for the blockade
to be lifted those demands included
cutting ties off with iran shutting down
al jazeera
expelling turkish turkish military base
here
and paying billions of dollars of
compensation to
those four countries um what's very
clear
uh in what's happened and people will
say well why
an obvious question why is there a
breakthrough now if those demands aren't
being
met there's been a shift in uh
international uh players in terms of the
new u.s administration that's on the
brink of
inauguration in terms of the fact that
qatar has established that it has been
able to survive
over the past three years not just
survive but actually its economy has
been doing better than
the four blockading countries and
therefore
the policies that have been pushed by
that quartet have obviously failed
that coupled with the constant
push and efforts by kuwait to try and
find a solution
and the revived interest of
uh u.s president donald trump's senior
adviser and son-in-law jared kushner
to maybe exit the white house with
another
diplomatic win as far as he's concerned
is what
led us to where we are today um
speaking to people not just in qatar but
also
in kuwait and across the gcc what i
understand will take place tomorrow will
focus more on
an emphasis of the unity of the gcc
the need to uh bring about uh or
re-establish
uh a united front uh towards the
different crises
that they will face not least kovid
which has been a major one that they've
all
suffered equally from and also a
a a kind of a reaffirmation
of the gcc's principles and a return to
the mechanisms that's already existed in
it
in order to find a solution
as far as the saudis are concerned and
this is why so far
the only airspace that will be open or
has been announced to be open is saudi
arabia
they are maybe in a le i wouldn't say a
better position but a less worse
position than
the emiratis and the bahrainis um and
the egyptians because
of the geopolitical nature that they
find themselves in
as the custodians of the two holy
shrines or as the
self-proclaimed leaders of the muslim
world they can always fall back on that
as a reason why
they are going to be the quote-unquote
bigger person and find
a way to reunite things jamal just you
mentioned in passing
iran and and how that sort of played
into this whole
dispute what do you think the future is
for the relations between
uh the countries in that area and iran
well i mean it's it's a relationship
that's been hot and cold and
to a great extent actually uh a lot of
times
it's been kind of very confusing because
you find for example the blockading
countries demanding
from qatar ties with iran but one of the
blockading countries namely
the united arab emirates does business
in
the trade volume between abu dhabi and
tehran is tenfold
greater than that of doha and
iran there have been senior uae
officials that have gone to tehran
over the past year in a bid to try and
maybe
find a different approach towards it
that's one of the differences between
for example the uae and saudi arabia
in terms of foreign policy it's also
been obviously one of the difference
between
both those countries and qatar which has
tried to always play a mediating role as
well as for example oman which was
one of the countries that paved the way
for the
iranian nuclear deal as well as other
negotiations with
tehran in terms of looking forward to it
a couple of weeks ago the deputy foreign
minister of
iran was in doha no doubt discussions
would have taken place or at least he
would have
been given some sort of visibility as to
the discussions taking place to find
a solution to the gcc crisis but
ultimately um this crisis will or
this resolution to the crisis will be
seen
detached from the individual
relationships between
each country and iran because one of the
key
uh talking points that the qatari
officials have been making throughout
the past three years
is that the blockade was being imposed
on them to try and enforce
uh or strip them rather of their
independence and their
uh sovereignty in making or pursuing
specific foreign policies and therefore
wouldn't make sense
for them to accept any sort of dictation
as to how they would deal with iran or
any other country for that matter
in order to resolve the issue tell us a
bit about the the gcc
um now that well it appears that this
big dispute is on course being resolved
at any rate it does the gcc
have a new position or a kind of new
power in the region i mean
in the past it's been criticized for not
having enough influence or not
perhaps you know perhaps making big
enough decisions on
crises or conflicts well how do you see
the future of the gcc if this
particular issue is resolved
well if we were to look at the wider
middle east and north africa region
the gcc is probably the most functioning
uh block between them so the arab the
league of arab states
or the arab league has been one that
many have criticized for failing to do
anything on any front the gcc at least
had certain things like
visa waiver between the countries had
economic
privileges uh often negotiated uh
trade deals and so forth as a block and
and therefore there was some sort of a
benefit to it politically speaking when
it came
to issues of pursuing specific policies
uh particularly when it came to
international uh events that's where it
had a problem
obviously we're reporting on the facts
right the fact is that these are
countries that don't
uh see eye to eye on issues also if
we're
to be blunt about describing any
possible
solution that will take place tomorrow
the reality is
it's not really going to solve the deep
seeded issues between these countries
because each country is built on a
different political system and has a
different
outlook qatar is a lot more pluralistic
in its approach it's a lot more open to
uh diversity and to different of
of opinions and deals with countries
from iran to israel in the past right
whereas the united arab emirates saudi
arabia
bahrain and egypt have consistently
pursued
more unilateral
policies have supported consistently
authoritarian regimes either military
ones like the
one in egypt or in in libya
or absolute monarchies and therefore
that hasn't changed so
if you are to follow the
analysis that is that the core of the
issue is
that difference of opinion particularly
when we're looking at it post arab
spring
then really all that's been happening is
you're putting a plaster on a gushing
wound
but that is enough at least for many
people in the region because
the stability that came from the gcc
even if it was
fractured behind the scenes was still
something that is worth
maintaining as opposed to having yet
another
divided and fractured segment of the
middle east and north africa
jamal thank you very much indeed for the
time being and now let's
bring in ramy kuri who's the director of
global engagement and a senior public
policy fellow at the american university
of beirut joins us via skype
from new york hopefully your line will
stay stable this time now listen i
wanted to ask you about the
where this puts the biden administration
and and its future relations
say with with iran does this complicate
the task for for biden and how to deal
with iran the fact that uh
uh that this result that this situation
has been is being resolved i don't think
so i think it probably is a positive
element
the the arab countries in the arab
region and the ones in the gulf and the
gcc
don't have a united position unified
position on iran some of them want to
use
forceful sanctions and threats and put
military options on the table other ones
want to have quiet diplomacy
but reducing the tensions between the
gcc countries and
qatar will definitely be a positive step
and the question of iran is going to
depend much more
on what people decide in washington and
maybe a little bit in israel
because israel drives a lot of
washington policy on this
that's going to be the determining
factor but qatar
has qatar and kuwait and all men have
good
relations with iran trading they talk
they're in
contact all the time and that's a very
positive thing
the the genesis of this conflict between
the or the blockade
uh because it's not really a two-way
conflict but the genesis was the
the saudis and the emiratis were
terrified after the arab uprisings of
210 to 11
about trends in the region democracy
voting leaders being thrown out open
media like jazeera and others
but they were also worried about the
united states starting to negotiate with
iran and the u.s pulling out of the
region
so having a sensible logical
political dialogue between iran and the
arab countries
is the only way to to to do this and
you've had some saudis and emiratis and
others
behind the scenes talking to to iranians
so we'll have to wait and see there's
also a new factor here which is some
countries possibly without naming any
because we don't know this is
speculation but some arab countries may
feel that their
links with israel may give them more
comfort in terms of dealing
with iran if the us is slowly
downgrading its role in the region
which it may or may not be but the links
with israel are also a new factor
that we have to put into this into this
situation but the real driver of this
whole
boycott issue was the united arab
emirates muhammad bin zayed
the crown prince and effective ruler of
the uae rather than
the saudis the bahrainis and the
egyptians went along with it because
they basically
gained a lot of material things and a
sense of sort of a role in the region
but the saudis are much more sensitive
to the damage
that has been done to their reputation
because of this because
the blockade because of the war in yemen
because of the internal factors that
they've
dealt with in terms of repression so the
saudis are much more sensitive to
international opinion the muratis are
much more forceful and decisive
and we don't know the relationship
between them right now it seems to be
evolving and we haven't heard anything
about
the emiratis opening their border or
doing anything so we have to really wait
to get more information about what is
the result of this
reconciliation or reduction in tension
opening of some borders
but it's a positive move everybody
should welcome it and people should
not repeat such foolhardy unilateral
blockades
that are based on political differences
that
translate into acts of almost irrational
political violence now tommy you
mentioned that in passing the
normalization of relations between some
gulf countries
with israel give us an idea of whether
this actually some of that might be tied
to this and in what in what way
well it might be the emiratis have
established
normal relations and some of them are
enthusiastic about economic ties of
course we don't know what the emirati
people feel about this the likelihood is
not all emiratis
are happy with this we know that around
the entire arab region
somewhere around 70 to 80 percent of the
population of the arab countries don't
want to normalize with israel until
israel
has a fair peace with the palestinians
then everybody's willing to normalize
the arab peace plan is based on normal
relations with israel which came out of
saudi arabia
and the arab summit years ago but we
don't know what average people around
the region think the normalization is a
is a is a logistical
mutually beneficial agreement between
individual leaders
in bahrain in the uae and morocco sudan
even the whole government isn't
behind the normalization or the steps
towards normalization the
military side wants to do it the
political side in sudan doesn't so
these are very delicate uh limited
depth uh logistical arrangements
rather than peace breaking out or
anything like that the
the interesting thing here also is the
announcement for this came out of kuwait
not out of washington as far as i can
tell those things may have changed in
the last 15 minutes
the united states wants to play this up
as a big deal and jared kushner is
trying to
take a lot of credit for it the
likelihood is that the omanis
and the kuwaitis did much most of the
heavy lifting in terms of
discussions and and how to get this
resolved
but again we just have to wait for the
details these things
are not completely clear right the
details are not completely clear right
now
and this may be a limited but
significant first step
towards reducing the tensions and
eventually getting back
to normal relations but normal relations
as your correspondence said
mean that different gulf countries have
different policies
they're different in their economic
weight their ideology
the nature of their leadership their
relationship to open societies and close
societies they're very very different
from each other
they've never had a strong unified
position on anything political really
and even they when they did say on
palestine they just broke it
because they thought they had things to
benefit so it has never been a major
political
bloc but it has been a functioning
uh technical uh collaboration among
these six
like-minded countries which started at
the moment in the 1970s
when i was i'm old enough to remember
when it started and it was very much
seen as a rich
arab rich persons club to protect the
wealth of the arab
gulf region that suddenly boomerang the
mushroomed in the 70s when oil prices
increased and people saw the gcc as a
way for the gulf countries to
try to protect their wealth and
and it never had any real political
weight and has much less now there's
another danger here
the uae and the saudis especially the
uae may suffer what the trump
administration
has suffered which is a drop in trust
internationally people might say well i
can't make a deal with this country
because they'll just break it
unilaterally
like trump did with different you know
climate change and
other things and the emiratis and saudis
just unilaterally broke
the relations with qatar boycotted them
started the war in yemen
and this kind of unilateral impulsive
often violent
behavior whether it's military or just
political violence
this is a problem for many countries
because others will look twice before
making
agreements with them in the future ramey
corey thank you very much indeed
for your analysis